se a fx igual a 2 x cuadrada menos 18
todo esto dividido entre g x donde gx es
un polinomio la pregunta es cuál de las
siguientes opciones es una posible
gráfica de igual a fx y como siempre las
líneas punteadas indican a cinto estás
muy bien entonces aquí tenemos cuatro
opciones
estas cuatro opciones de gráficas verdad
algunas de ellas podría representar a la
a la función de igual a fx verdad
entonces te invito a que hagas una pausa
trates de resolver este problema por tu
propia cuenta y después lo haremos todos
juntos
muy bien entonces vamos a resolver este
problema todos juntos verdad y lo que
podemos ahora hacer es notar que en
realidad no nos dan mucha información
verdad no nos dan información por
ejemplo de quiénes gdx lo único que nos
dicen es que es un polinomio y por
supuesto que x aparece en el denominador
de esta expresión racional verdad sin
embargo si nos dicen quién es el
numerador y como hemos visto
anteriormente es útil factorizar lo y
ver algunos valores interesantes de x en
particular valdría la pena ver los
valores de x donde el numerador se anula
muy bien entonces vamos a hacer esto
aquí vamos a tener f x verdad y por
ejemplo aquí podríamos primero
factorizar un 2 verdad aquí podríamos
poner 2 que multiplica a x cuadrada
menos 9 y todo esto irá dividido entre g
de x y lo que podemos notar ahora es que
aquí tenemos una diferencia de cuadrados
verdad esto sería x
- 3 al cuadrado entonces esto lo podemos
factorizar con binomios conjugados
verdad entonces esto quedaría como 2 x x
+ 3 que multiplica a x menos 3 y luego
todo esto va dividido aún entre g x así
que si esto te pareció algo digamos
desconocido te invito a que veas el
vídeo sobre la diferencia de cuadrados
muy bien entonces aquí tenemos que el
numerador se va a poder anular en x
igual a menos tres verdades cuando este
factor de aquí se anula o bien cuando x
es igual a 3 que sería el segundo factor
verdad entonces tanto en digamos vamos a
ponerlo así
efe de menos 3 es podría ser 0 esto
podría en principio ser cero y efe de 3
podría ser en principio 0 verdad así que
vamos a ver qué ocurre con estas
gráficas que tenemos aquí estas opciones
analicemos qué pasa primero con la
gráfica
muy bien entonces podemos ver que en x
igual a 3 en efecto la función corta al
eje horizontal verdad al eje x es decir
es un cero de nuestra función muy bien
ahora bien en x igual a menos 3 podemos
ver que tenemos una cinta vertical suena
bastante bastante curioso verdad no
sabemos qué va a pasar con a veamos qué
pasa con la opción b aquí nuevamente
tenemos que en 3 x está nuestro eje
horizontal verdad es una raíz o un 0 de
la función y en menos 3 tenemos que la
función está definida verdad aquí
tenemos que la función está definida
entonces esto también suena en principio
algo algo curioso veamos qué pasa ahora
con la opción c aquí en tres tenemos una
discontinuidad removible verdad aquí
tenemos una discontinuidad removible
- 3 tenemos que la función está también
definida verdad más o menos aquí
tendremos el valor en menos 3 entonces
esto vuelve a ser otra vez algo
interesante es verdad y finalmente en la
opción de tenemos que tanto en menos 3
más o menos toma ese valor como en 3 más
o menos tomará este valor este pues no
pasa nada ni en menos 3 mientras es
verdad entonces parece ser que hay algo
raro con estas cuatro opciones y en
principio ninguna de estas cuatro
opciones tiene ceros tanto en x igual a
tres como en x menos 3 bebé debería
haber en ambas opciones y esto porque
podría ocurrir bueno tenemos que darnos
cuenta que el hecho de que el numerador
se anule el hecho de que nuestro
numerador se anule no implica que
tengamos un cero de la función verdad y
bueno tú te preguntarás cómo es posible
que esto ocurra bueno pues vamos a
pensar en algunas situaciones en donde
podamos ver
por ejemplo pensemos en una opción para
gdx pensemos que fx sería 2 x x + 3
por x 3 y digamos que está dividido
entre un polinomio particular digamos x
+ 1 pensemos ahorita que g es x + 1 ok
entonces aquí podemos ver que justamente
la función efe tiene dos ceros vamos a
poner esto la función f tiene dos ceros
o también se le dice que tiene dos
raíces verdad y en este caso serían
menos tres y tres verdad y eso es porque
el denominador no se anula en ninguno de
estos dos ahora que otro tipo de
opciones tenemos bueno tenemos por
ejemplo podríamos poner fx igualados por
equis más tres que multiplica a x menos
tres y digamos que dividimos entre x + 3
que multiplica a x más 1 este podría ser
un ejemplo verdad entonces aquí podemos
ver que tenemos un
x igual a 3 verdad porque en el
numerador se cancela verdad gracias a
este factor sin embargo en x igual a
menos 3 ahora podríamos cancelar estos
factores tanto en el numerador como en
el denominador eso quiere decir que
tenemos una discontinuidad removible y
lo voy a poner así una discontinuidad
removible
x igual a menos 3 entonces en este caso
tendríamos una discontinuidad re móvil y
removible perdón en x igual a menos 3 oa
lo mejor podríamos elegir otra función
que que por ejemplo haga que tengamos
una discontinuidad removible en 3 y un 0
en menos 3 o quizás ambas podrían tener
discontinuidades removibles verdad en
cuyo caso la función que debería tener
un factor x + 3 y un factor x menos 3
veamos que otro tipo de opciones
podríamos inventarnos podríamos tener fx
igual a bueno el numerador es siempre el
mismo 2 por x + 3 por x menos 3 y por
ejemplo podríamos dividir entre x + 3 al
cuadrado por x + 1 ok en este caso qué
es lo que ocurre pues uno de estos este
este factor que está en el numerador se
cancela con uno de los factores x + 3
del denominador y entonces que es lo que
tendríamos tendríamos 1
en 0 en x igual a 3 que corresponde a
este factor de aquí pero ahora no
tendríamos ni un 0 en x igual a menos 3
ni tampoco una discontinuidad removible
removible en este caso sería una a sin
tota y luego poner asia sin total
vertical ok en x igual a menos 3 verdad
entonces aquí vemos que las raíces del
numerador no necesariamente son raíces
de nuestra función original podrían ser
ceros de la función original podrían ser
así en total us into estás verticales o
discontinuidades removibles así que
regresemos a nuestros cuatro ejemplos y
veamos si ahora sí podríamos determinar
cuál de estas cuatro opciones representa
mejor a la función entonces para el caso
a en x igual a 3 tenemos 1
0 y en x igual a menos 3 tenemos una
cinta vertical entonces en principio a
es una muy buena elección qué pasaría
con b bueno en vez tenemos un cero en x
igual a 3 pero en menos 3 no tenemos ni
un 0 ni una cinta vertical ni una
discontinuidad removible verdad entonces
esta no es una opción veamos qué pasa
ahora en c en x igual a 3 tenemos una
discontinuidad removible y en menos 3
tenemos que la función está definida
entonces y de hecho no vale 0 entonces
esta opción no es una no es una viable
no es una opción viable y finalmente en
la opción de bueno podemos ver que tanto
en tres como en menos tres la función
tiene un valor definido que no es cero
es decir no es una raíz no son raíces no
son ceros así que de tampoco es una
opción así que finalmente concluimos que
la opción
es una muy buena elección para la
gráfica de nuestra función f x